hello everybody and welcome back it's
played dead space - okay we got a huge
marker and their bodies of
was flying up to the sky why
but it's happening
spinning up
poor fellow's
don't feel bad in the least forum
even even now with all Miami I've got
plenty Vince
Pegasus
I mean damn
Oh get in here
just like straw setting Oh No
the machine activates the parts of our
brain where the marker codes are stored
how does that threaten the marker it
doesn't over their photo they're not me
working together yeah I don't think so
step four
are you ready no this is gonna hurt us
step
why am I doing this why am I going
inside this very diabolical engine
step to this cruise so tired
Oh cross my heart
Oh what I gotta get it in his eyeball
are you kidding me ha ha ha can I only
do it yeah oh my god really oh my god
I'm guessing that he'll die
hold still eyes oh it's a heart rate
okay Oh an old monitor showing me how
close I am oh I see I can't make him
panic good I'd be worried - Isaac which
is hold still
oh my gosh shut up shut up shut up shut
up shut up shut up hang on one point two
away very close now i'ma hold still
buddy and ya gonna get ah
oh my eyes bleeding oh why why do that
that was my shooting eye Oh uh-huh
Nicole
where are you why did I need that the
markers already built follow the light
Isaac I'll be waiting for you in the
marker right what do I do
okay Alec Weiss very bad idea
Oh chapter 14 okay it's glowing a bit
redder whoa
that ah
hello
I see
womp oh no oh it's the dude it's the big
guy from oh holy crap this is not good
I just gotta I gotta get him
still
got to get him to Ariel and then I'm
gonna rip this off get his gun quickly
very quickly fine chukkamma Marie ha ha
no no no I got it
ah good good good I got do it oh wow
holy [ __ ] that hurt good ah wow I really
good hits hard huh ok save jeez oh man
oh hi guys gonna be stalked me like in
the last game
no don't you dare tell me what I can and
cannot do on my own station
my grandfather was running this place
long before you were crapping your
diapers young man I don't need a lecture
from you and you know I'm right
Roger protocol specifically forbids
evacuation in the event of a breach I
offered my whole life in service of this
community
ah home
to discuss your personal call oh he's
not gonna
damn
all right I still don't know how I'm
gonna break it down
now I got aa
that was that it's shaking
hello targets hit my targets
everything's shaken because I got ah
come on you go sprint right there damn
you damn everything about you
do you and your family oh man please
oh I located the two remaining 143
second G personnel they're lucky
ah do it do it do it god damn it was the
[ __ ] delay oh I need to get the body
you got to be kidding me you're the
[ __ ] health kid what the [ __ ] am I
out am I really out of health kits
No shut up and just stay there I am
seriously out of it out of help get out
of my way you've got to be [ __ ] me
how can I be out of health kids I had
tons and I didn't get hurt at all since
the last oh [ __ ] hell
this [ __ ] god
I am not I'm not
I have many I'm ass Cupidon it did not
heal me oh my god
oh man
that is aggravation I was slamming the
cue button
oh I don't need to listen
oh so you're back up a long tough okay
there you go
harmless that Oh give me that
there we go okay ah you you
Oh way when you lose what you're kidding
me
[ __ ] kidding me you son of a few -
what the hell how can what how never
mind
shut up
shut up go away Oh criminy Christmas
play what
shut up
shut up ah you gotta be joking me right
where the [ __ ] is the elevator you gotta
be joking all right line gun
no go away
ah redonkulous
donkey Elizabeth winning strategy is
just a move get back out of there
oh shut up I'm leaving I'm leaving I'm
leaving you nope come on out of here let
me through please
anti-gravity I will escape you in the
sky let me up Simeon up and do the sky
oh let me through yep
I'm not joking around now ah come on
Wow Oh what the hell what the hell
I you're gonna really what's hitting me
why is it mate seriously what is hitting
me I want to know again what something
is [ __ ] pushing me around oh [ __ ] I
can't [ __ ] hit my target I'm not
shooting straight oh this [ __ ] I'm
just [ __ ]
oh now you're dead man
everything everything wants to get on my
nerves everything
oh go away
shut up I know you
shut up I do not trust you lady I will
never trust you I I don't care I do not
care about you anything about you oh I
would have thought that I would have
gotten to be ending already even in that
I was like just at the Mart hello on
another car wonderful direct market
marker access here we go this is what
I'm talking about
hello Ben cheese store oh man I swear
everything get nominees and I'm
officially out of med kit school is
actually aren't big enough I need I need
I need the big ones the medium work is
more than anything not the giant once I
just need the big ones uh um someone
said that I need to upgrade my health I
might as well do that it's kind of been
problematic okay whew I'm fine I'm okay
why is it gotta be just like that
why's it got to be like that I can't
even get to the last one but whatever a
little bit and more damage on the tea
cake and bailment shut up you're so
thirsty
this is it this is like the final boss
battle you're not joking with me you're
not then if that's the case I need to
get maybe a bit more ammo Wow what the
hell ah
oh you're an [ __ ] oh you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I swear
by actually a gun should be enough to be
enough to get by if this is if this it
really is like the final boss all right
if this is then I'm gonna end it here
it's pretty close to the end of the my
normal end time anyways so I'm gonna cut
it here so that if that if right after
this is the boss then I want the whole
boss battle to be the whole last bit to
be one episode so thank you guys so much
for watching and as always we'll see you
in the next part
bye bye